et le thermomètre, sur le porche, indiquait -40 degrés --
inutile de préciser Celsius ou Fahrenheit,
-40 est la température où les deux échelles se rejoignent --
il faisait très froid.
Sur le pas de la porte, en fouillant mes poches,
j'ai réalisé que je n'avais pas mes clés.
En fait, je pouvais les voir à travers la fenêtre,
posées sur la table du salon où je les avais laissées.
J'ai donc fait le tour pour essayer les autres portes et fenêtres.
Elles étaient toutes fermées.
J'ai pensé appeler un serrurier -- au moins j'avais mon portable,
mais à minuit, il aurait fallu attendre un moment que le serrurier arrive
et il faisait froid.
Je ne pouvais pas retourner chez mon ami pour la nuit
car j'avais un avion pour l'Europe tôt le lendemain,
et je devais récupérer mon passeport et ma valise.
Désespéré et en train de geler,
j'ai pris un gros rocher et j'ai brisé la fenêtre du sous-sol,
j'ai enlevé les éclats de verre,
je me suis faufilé à l'intérieur,
j'ai trouvé un morceau de carton et l'ai scotché pour couvrir l'ouverture
en me disant que le lendemain, en allant à l'aéroport,
j'appellerais un prestataire pour lui demander de réparer ça.
Cela allait me coûter cher,
mais probablement pas plus qu'une intervention de nuit,
donc au vu des circonstances, je ne m'en sortais pas mal.
Je suis un neuroscientifque de formation
et je sais un peu comment fonctionne le cerveau en cas de stress.
Il libère du cortisol, ce qui augmente le rythme cardiaque,
module les niveaux d'adrénaline
et embrouille votre raisonnement.
Du coup, le lendemain matin,
quand je me suis réveillé après une nuit trop courte,
préoccupé par le trou dans la fenêtre,
et un mémo mental pour me rappeler d'appeler un vitrier,
et les températures glaciales,
et les réunions qui m'attendaient en Europe,
et, vous savez, avec tout le cortisol dans mon cerveau,
ma refléxion était trouble,
mais je ne le savais pas, car ma refléxion était trouble.
(Rires)
Et ce n'est qu'à l'arrivée au comptoir d'enregistrement,
que j'ai réalisé que je n'avais pas mon passeport.
(Rires)
J'ai donc couru chez moi dans la neige et la glace pendant 40 minutes,
j'ai pris mon passeport, j'ai couru à l'aéroport,
je suis arrivé juste à l'heure,
mais ils avaient donné mon siège à quelqu'un d'autre,
et je me suis retrouvé à l'arrière de l'avion, près des toilettes,
sur un siège qui ne s'inclinait pas, sur un vol de 8 heures.
J'ai eu le temps de réfléchir pendant ces 8 heures sans sommeil.
(Rires)
Et j'ai commencé à me demander s'il y avait
des systèmes que je pouvais mettre en place,
pour empêcher les mauvaises choses de se produire ?
Ou, au moins, si de mauvaises choses arrivaient,
permettraient de minimiser la probabilité que ce soit une catastrophe totale.
Donc, j'ai commencé à penser à cela,
mais mes pensées ne se sont clarifiées qu'un mois plus tard.
Je dînais avec mon collègue, Danny Kahneman, le prix Nobel
et je lui ai dit, un peu embarrassé, avoir cassé ma fenêtre
et oublié mon passeport,
et Danny m'a raconté
qu'il s'était mis à pratiquer une méthode appelée « recul prospectif ».
(Rires)
Il avait découvert cela par le psychologue Gary Klein,
qui avait écrit à ce sujet quelques années plus tôt,
aussi appelé le « pre-mortem ».
Vous savez tous ce que signifie post-mortem.
Chaque fois qu'il y a une catastrophe,
une équipe d'experts vient et essaie de comprendre ce qui a mal tourné.
Dany m'a expliqué que dans le « pre-mortem »,
vous tentez de prévoir tout ce qui pourrait mal tourner,
puis vous imaginez ce que vous pourriez faire
pour empêcher ces choses de se produire, ou minimiser les dommages.
Je veux donc vous parler aujourd'hui
des différentes façons dont nous pouvons appliquer le pre-mortem.
Certaines sont évidentes, d'autres moins.
Tout d'abord, les plus évidentes.
Autour de la maison, choisissez un lieu pour les choses qui se perdent facilement.
Évidemment, cela semble relever du bon sens, et c'est le cas,
mais la science est là pour appuyer cette thèse,
basée sur la façon dont fonctionne notre mémoire spatiale.
Il y a une partie du cerveau appelée l'hippocampe,
qui a évolué au cours de dizaines de milliers d'années,
pour garder la trace des emplacements des choses importantes --
où est le puits, où on peut trouver du poisson,
l'emplacement des arbres fruitiers,
où vivent les tribus amies et ennemies.
L'hippocampe est la partie du cerveau
qui s'élargit chez les chauffeurs de taxis de Londres.
C'est la partie du cerveau qui permet aux écureuils de trouver leurs noix.
Si vous vous posez la question, quelqu'un a fait l'expérience
d'enlever le sens olfactif de certains écureuils
et ils trouvaient toujours leurs noix.
Ils n'utilisaient pas leur odorat, mais leur hippocampe,
ce mécanisme magnifiquement évolué dans le cerveau pour trouver des choses.
Mais ce n'est efficace que pour les objets qui ne bougent pas,
pas tant pour ceux qui sont mobiles.
C'est donc pourquoi nous perdons nos clés, lunettes de lecture et passeports.
Donc, chez vous, choisissez un lieu pour vos clés --
un crochet à côté de la porte, peut-être un bol décoratif.
Pour votre passeport, un tiroir particulier.
Pour vos lunettes de lecture, une table en particulier.
Si vous désignez un endroit et êtes scrupuleux à ce sujet,
vos affaires seront toujours là quand vous les chercherez.
Et pour les voyages ?
Prenez des photos de vos cartes de crédit,
de votre permis de conduire, de votre passeport,
envoyez-les vous par mail pour que ce soit en ligne.
Si ces derniers sont volés ou perdus, cela facilitera leur remplacement.
Ce sont des choses assez évidentes.
Rappelez-vous, en situation de stress, le cerveau sécrète du cortisol.
Le cortisol est toxique, et trouble les pensées.
Ainsi, une partie de la pratique du pre-mortem
consiste à reconnaître que, sous stress, vous ne serez pas le meilleur de vous-même
et que vous devriez mettre en place des systèmes.
Il n'y a probablement pas de situation plus stressante
que lorsque vous êtes confronté à une prise de décision médicale.
Et tôt ou tard, nous serons tous confrontés à cette situation,
où nous devons prendre une décision importante
à propos de l'avenir de nos soins médicaux ou de ceux d'un être cher,
pour les aider à prendre une décision.
Je veux donc parler de cela
et je vais parler d'une maladie en particulier.
Mais ce modèle peut être appliqué à toute décision médicale,
ainsi que pour des prises de décisions financières ou sociales --
toute sorte de décision que vous auriez à prendre
qui pourrait bénéficier d'une évaluation rationnelle des faits.
Imaginons que vous alliez chez le docteur et qu'il dise :
« Je viens de recevoir vos résultats, votre taux de cholestérol est élevé. »
Bien sûr vous savez tous qu'un cholestérol élevé
est associé avec une augmentation des risques cardiovasculaires,
de crise cardiaque, d'AVC.
Alors, vous vous dites
qu'avoir un cholestérol élevé n'est pas bon.
Le médecin vous dit : « Je voudrais vous donner un traitement
pour baisser votre taux de cholestérol, une statine. »
Vous en avez probablement entendu parler,
elles font partie des médicaments les plus prescrits,
vous connaissez probablement des personnes qui en prennent.
Alors, vous vous dites : « Oui ! Donnez-moi de la statine. »
Mais il y a une question que vous devriez poser,
une statistique que vous devriez demander
dont la plupart des docteurs n'aiment pas parler
et dont les groupes pharmaceutiques aiment encore moins parler.
C'est le nombre de sujets à traiter (NST).
Mais que représente ce NST ?
C'est le nombre de personnes qui doivent prendre un médicament,
subir une opération ou une intervention médicale
pour qu'une personne soit guérie.
Et vous pensez : « Pourquoi une statistique aussi tordue ?
Le nombre devrait être 1.
Mon médecin ne me prescrirait pas quelque chose qui ne m'aiderait pas. »
Mais en fait, la pratique médicale ne marche pas ainsi.
Et ce n'est pas la faute du médecin,
ce serait plutôt la faute de scientifiques comme moi.
Nous n'avons pas assez bien compris les mécanismes sous-jacents.
Mais GlaxoSmithKline estime
que 90% des médicaments fonctionnent sur seulement 30 à 50% des gens.
Donc le nombre de sujets à traiter pour la statine la plus prescrite,
que pensez-vous que ce soit ?
Combien de personnes doivent en prendre pour qu'une soit soignée ?
300.
Ce résultat est d'après une recherche
des practiciens chercheurs Jerome Groopman et Pamela Hartzband,
confirmé en parallèle par Bloomberg.com.
J'ai étudié les nombres moi-même.
300 personnes doivent prendre le traitement pendant un an
avant qu'un arrêt cardiaque, un AVC ou un autre problème soit évité.
Vous pensez alors probablement :
« Bon, OK, une chance sur 300 de baisser mon cholestérol.
Pourquoi pas ? Donnez-moi quand même l'ordonnance. »
Mais vous devriez alors demander une autre statistique,
à savoir : « Qu'en est-il des effets indésirables ? »
Pour ce médicament en particulier,
5% des patients subissent des effets indésirables.
Entre autres, des choses affreuses --
muscles affaiblis, douleurs articulaires, troubles gastro-intestinaux --
mais vous vous dites :
« 5% il y a peu de chance que ça m'arrive,
je prends quand même le médicament. »
Mais attendez.
Etant stressé, vous ne pensez pas clairement.
Pensez alors à la façon de traiter cette étape en avance
pour que vous n'ayez pas à construire tout un raisonnement au débotté.
300 personnes prennent le médicament, une personne est soignée,
les effets secondaires affectent 5% de ces 300,
c'est à dire 15 personnes.
Il y a 15 fois plus de chances que le médicament vous fasse du mal
plutôt qu'il ne vous soigne.
Ceci dit, je ne dis pas que vous devez prendre le médicament ou non.
Je dis juste que vous devriez en discuter avec votre médecin.
L'éthique médicale l'exige,
cela fait partie du principe du consentement éclairé.
Vous avez le droit d'accéder à ce type d'information,
de commencer la conversation sur votre souhait de prendre les risques.
Vous pensez peut-être
que j'ai sorti ce chiffre au hasard pour vous choquer,
mais en fait il est plutôt typique, ce nombre de sujets à traiter.
Pour la chirurgie la plus effectuée chez des hommes ayant plus de 50 ans,
l'ablation de la prostate à cause d'un cancer,
le nombre de sujets à traiter est 49.
Oui, 49 chirurgies sont effectuées pour qu'une personne soit guérie.
Et les effets secondaires dans ce cas se présentent chez 50% des patients.
Ils incluent l'impuissance, la dysfonction érectile,
l'incontinence urinaire, la fissure anale,
l'incontinence fécale.
Et si vous êtes chanceux et que vous faites partie des 50%,
ils ne dureront qu'un an ou deux.
Ainsi, l'idée du pre-mortem est de penser préalablement
aux questions que vous pourriez poser
et qui feraient avancer la conversation.
Vous ne devez pas réfléchir à tout ça sur le vif
et vous devez aussi penser à votre qualité de vie.
Parce que vous avez souvent le choix,
préférez-vous une vie plus courte, mais sans douleur
ou une vie plus longue comportant de grandes souffrances sur la fin ?
Ce sont des choses dont vous devez parler dès maintenant,
avec votre famille et vos proches.
Vous pourriez changer d'avis au moment fatidique,
mais au moins vous vous seriez entraîné à y réfléchir.
Rappelez-vous, en situation de stress, notre cerveau sécrète du cortisol
et ce qui arrive à ce moment, entre autres,
c'est qu'un tas de systèmes s'arrêtent.
Il y a une raison liée à l'évolution.
Face à un prédateur, vous n'avez pas besoin de votre système digestif,
de votre libido ou de votre système immunitaire,
parce que si votre corps consacre son métabolisme à ces derniers
et que vous ne réagissez pas rapidement,
vous pourriez devenir le repas du lion et alors rien de tout cela ne comptera.
Malheureusement,
l'un des éléments qui tombe à l'eau dans ces moments de stress
est le raisonnement logique,
comme l'ont démontré Danny Kahneman et ses collègues.
Nous avons donc besoin de nous entraîner à réfléchir en amont
de ces types de situations.
Je pense que le point important ici est de reconnaître que nous avons des défauts.
Nous allons échouer de temps en temps.
L'idée est de réfléchir en amont à ce que ces échecs pourraient être,
mettre en place des systèmes qui minimiseront les dégâts
ou empêcheront les désagréments d'arriver en premier lieu.
Revenons à cette nuit enneigée à Montreal,
quand je suis revenu de mon voyage,
j'ai fait installer une serrure à combinaison près de la porte,
avec la clé à l'intérieur et une combinaison simple à retenir.
Et je dois l'admettre,
j'ai toujours une pile de courrier non trié
et un pile d'emails que je n'ai pas lus.
Je ne suis donc pas complèment organisé,
mais je perçois l'organisation comme une démarche progressive,
et je suis en bonne voie.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)